I'm not trying to be a victim, Andy. Okay. But in the >> there's
nothing there's nothing better than going I'm not trying to be
a victim, guys. I don't want to be a victim, but here's literally
everything that's gone wrong in my life. >> I've had every
single person around me basically doxed into non-existent such
that my studio downstairs is now currently a drag waste of money,
right? Because even the guy that was doing the podcast was getting
harassed so much that like he has to back down. I have to the
left of me. People like Assan [__] are just straight
>> having that having that backto back. The the person
who used to do a podcast with you, that's so much harassment.
And then look at the way that Hassan is harassing me. Look at
the way that your co-host would harass Hassan. The unhinged websites
who a-logging all of his clips, put organizing them on websites
and providing them to ADL to Congress. Like look at this. >> You
want to attack to anybody who would listen, right? like and he
was really going hard. >> Where we got this? Uh, Counterpoints.
>> So, guys, Counterpoints decided to go on Destiny's stream
last night and do I I don't even know what this was supposed
to be. Uh,
the best I can describe it is
it's kind of like he's going there and he's like, "Destiny, I
heard you're thinking about retiring. Please don't. I've spent
so much time sweeping for you. I've spent so much time. I've
sacrificed so much of my own integrity to sweep for you. You
can't quit. You >> I lost culture thug. I can't lose you,
>> You lost everybody. But um hold on. Let me get the
You're a millionaire. You can hook up with plenty of young women.
>> You're you're infamous. >> I thought we were trying
to avoid this
>> Very weird. >> Well, we are, but if they're over
the age of 21 and you check their ID, I don't give a [__]
>> I know you, man. I know you
>> you're infamous.
>> You're you're to some degree you're internet famous.
You're successful within your craft. You've gone after two or
three different crafts. You've done quite well in two or three
different crafts.
And so abandoning your craft at the at the height of controversy,
at the height of adversary, I I I just don't think that that
is
>> is this music just super appropriate for no reason?
This this music is just perfect for what Connor is doing and
Destiny's is just a part of the game. That's that's wild. >> The
height of Adversary. I I I just don't think that that is
>> I mean I mean what do you what do you want to do? Do
you want to be comfortable
or do you want to do something great?
>> I feel like I've done a lot so far. I feel like I've
done okay
in terms of
>> right but you've done okay. So, the things that you've
done so far, okay, that I that I think are laudable. All right.
Uh, taking on canvasing operations by yourself, I think that's
laudable. Being willing to debate,
>> just to be clear, that's uh paying somebody else who
cares. That's
just just paying other people who care, which is okay, but it's
like not taking on not being like good at it yourself. is just
hiring good people and realistically getting approached by people
who had like a total what would you say like an obsession with
doing it well >> and then also finding a way to h to to
continue doing it and get the reputational buff for doing it
without actually having to fund it. That was the whole point
of progressive victory,
>> They were supposed to be able to fund >> They
were supposed to >> they were supposed to be able to fund
raise off his audience. That's not even out of his own pocket.
They I think they were supposed to bring funding on their own
off the bat, but yes, they failed to do that and then they fundraised
off of his audience. >> His audience Yeah. They didn't
fund raise very much. They're they've got bigger things that
they're worried about. They're funding the Ukraine side of that
war that's going on over there. >> They are they're
at a time staying up.
>> Operations by yourself. I think that's laudable. Being
willing to debate people large and small on almost any idea.
I think that's for a decade. I think that's laudable. Um I think
that the other thing that's laudable is doing uh working as much
as people criticize it, working with PV in order to do the canvasing
operations during the 24 election resulting in 1.6 million. >> Uh
his first thing and last thing are the same thing. >> Yeah.
And also resulting in a loss. >> Uh yes. >> Is Connor
going to acknowledge that
>> I I didn't even notice that the first time I saw this.
I watched like a I watched at least half of this before like
and he just said you're you did so well setting up canvasing
and then you did so well doing canvasing again in 202 >> that
resulted in
my sitting in meetings still making Democrats lose. >> Uh
listen, if Conor's only job is to take resources away from Democrats,
he's doing a fantastic job right now. >> Oh yeah. >> Yeah,
he's great at that. He is
>> I love the >> glaze. I I like I I understand I've
done loadable things. I just
>> Well, that's what I'm saying. So, why are you out now?
>> Okay. So, off the top of my head, okay, like the p over
the past
>> Oh, that is a hard one, too.
>> Did you hear him? He's like, I love the
Because he literally can't push away anybody willing to compliment
him. >> No. But you know, he sees this and he's like, "Geez,
Connor." >> No, I don't think so. I don't think so because
I think he knows.
I don't think he cares. I think he's like, "Yeah, come on, my
stream and humiliate yourself. Like, do it." >> I think
he's psyched for that most of the time. Yeah, >> I would
be embarrassed.
>> I I mean, I'm I'm embarrassed thirdand
secondhand embarrassment. Yeah. >> Yeah, secondhand embarrassment.
Yeah, >> embarrassed secondhand. But I just I'm laughing
again at the music I'm hearing from this next rant about being
a >> I'm not trying to be a victim, Andy. Okay. But in
the >> But there's nothing there's nothing better than
going, I'm not trying to be a victim, but here's a rant for like
two minutes about how much of a victim I am. There it's just
crazy that you do this, guys. I don't want to be a victim, but
here's literally everything that's gone wrong in my life for
the past month. >> And here is how none of it is my fault.
Yeah, there's nothing. There's no introspection. There's no analysis
of his own actions. It's just him talking about how unfair everybody
else is to >> You know what would be great?
>> Actually, never mind. No, no, it wouldn't be great.
>> Past month, I've had whatever is left of progressive
victory. Okay. It like turned into tankies and tried to do some
weird public disavow of me, which was weird because that whole
organization existed because of my community largely. That organization
existed for a long time before Desty's community. And also, this
just feeds into the exact Hassan narrative that was there. And
I'm positive somebody would have told him that, but he doesn't
care cuz they came out and it would I'll I'll be real. It was
weird that they came out like we don't like this guy anymore.
We actually love real progressives. I thought that was like a
weird disavow they did, but
for him to come out for him to come back and be like, "Oh, Hassan's
so because he says that this was a slush fund for my people,
but also I built it >> and he knows neither of those are
true." like there's a kind of >> but I also think he still
functions in this world where he's like
all of these people came from my community these are all my fans
he's very possessive so even though his fans are fans of other
people that he hates he regards them like as his fans or something
and so all these people just leeched off of him they grew off
of him but this is all his doing right yeah >> so even
though I wasn't on board with progressive victory are they Vosch
fans. Well, Vos is basically me. Those are all just from my community,
actually. >> It's all downstream, guys. It's all It's all
things he's built. Okay. I think I've heard him talk about that
how like, oh, even even with Bosch, even with Vos just built
off of me. Yeah. >> There will be shared the like shared
viewers, shared fans,
and they'll never be identified as anything but um his
>> Yeah. But they do that to themselves sometimes, too.
They can't they can't not defend him like everywhere.
>> just automatically do it. So >> that's true. Well,
that's because their streamer just hates, you know, presenting
himself as a victim, >> I guess. So, um I've had every
single person around me basically doxed into non-existent such
that my studio downstairs is now currently a drag waste of money,
right? Because even the guy I was doing the podcast with was
getting harassed so much that like he has to back down. I have
to the left of me. People like Asan [__] are just
>> Was did that Dan? >> Yeah, he's talking about
Dan.
It's like what happened where Dan backed away. I forget what
happened. It seemed like there was an event that happened where
Dan went whoa, this is too much. >> I think it was specifically
a Willy Mack video saying I reported
>> to the
Yeah. >> Yeah. I think I think right after that >> right
after that Dan said something about he's pausing
his episodes. I think he even stopped doing his show with Mutin.
Like I don't know why they made that decision. >> Well,
I think they went back to doing anything else with Moot. I guess
they're not doing it in that studio or >> No, Dan and Mutton
have a different show. They don't call it anything else, do they?
>> Uh Dan went and did anything else with Mr. Mootin. They
did an episode like last week >> or maybe this week >> from
anything else. I thought they have their own name. No, from the
anything else stuff cuz they I think I think basically they ended
clipped and shipped and they're just doing anything else now
because they have a Patreon for anything else which has got a
bunch of subscribers on it. They don't want to give up that money.
>> Got you.
>> So, he's doing it but without Steven. >> But without
Steven. Yeah.
>> That seems messy.
>> Yeah. I also don't know like technically he should be
able to run it out of that studio. I guess Mutton can't go to
that studio, so it would be weird. >> Well, Mutton's in
a different country, so he's just gonna
>> There's no reason for Dan to drive to Ty's place. >> Yeah.
I I feel like I don't know. I think that's fair. I think you
get to continue doing your podcast whether I
agree with your your beliefs or your hate towards the or not.
>> Yeah, sure. I'm just laughing that like Dan didn't even
stop doing the Dan is technically still doing the podcast. He
just doesn't want to do it with you. But he leaves that out conveniently.
>> Yeah. Well, he leaves out the whole event that preceded
it. Yeah. He leaves it all out. He He will never include when
he's in victim mode. He can't possibly see or include anything
he's actually done wrong. >> It's amazing. Reading down
my Kiwi Farms thread almost like weekly now. >> Oh, sorry.
>> On my Kiwi Farms thread almost No, no, no, hold on.
He was getting harassed so much that like he has to back down.
I have to the left of me. People like a son [__]
are just straight reading down my Kiwi Farms thread almost like
weekly now to try to >> having that having that backto
back.
The the person who used to do a podcast with you that's so much
harassment and then look at the way that Hassan is harassing
me.
Look at the way that your co-host would harass Hassan.
the unhinged websites who a-logging all of his clips put organizing
them on websites and providing them to ADL to Congress. Like
look at this
toone to anybody who would listen, right? Like and he was really
going hard. Like >> you have to be so comfortable being
a victim and having those two things come out of your mouth as
a complaint. >> Like you could call uh Quimman or me or
apparently even straight away anti-fans. You can call us antifans,
but we're not anywhere near the level of Dan being an anti-fan
of Hassan, right? That he will go to anyone who will listen.
He'll go to people who absolutely despise him. I've made jokes
about it like, "Oh, I could go to like the Republican like uh
I I could like DM some Republican on Twitter and like talk about,"
but I don't do it cuz I don't like actually want to go associate
with those people at all. >> Right. But Dan straight up
goes to anyone he can to do anything he can to Hassan. And then
Desi's like, "I have no idea why any of this comes back to me."
Uh, another thing. Oh, he reads down my Kiwi Farms thread. Yeah.
After you what gave Kiwi Farms the docs information to to go
after to find Rose, you read that thread multiple times yourself
on stream. Like are you mad that >> Oh, you have like a
personal dialogue with people in the thread.
>> Like you you fuel them. You You're the one who says,
"Don't give attention to these people." Oh, how dare Hassan give
attention to my kiwi farms. Like that you you do. >> Yeah.
You do. And that's the spe that's the exact kind of attention
they want. >> That's what fuels them. They don't give a
about Hassan there. Guess where they care about Hassan? On his
own thread. >> That's where they care.
>> Yeah, dude. The worst was um when he read out his his
girlfriend, ex-girlfriend's full name while reading out one of
the posts that was like mean to him. Just doesn't care. Doesn't
see the other part. It's It's insane. Anyway, hold on. I'll I'll
pull it back. We continue with this rant. We We were just at
>> to the left of me. People like a Sun [__]
are just straight reading down my Kiwi Farms thread almost like
weekly now to try to attack me as much as possible. Um I have
the exact same people who were supposedly on my team giving mad
props to and sucking off Assan whenever he makes up some new
story like the whole Pisco um TSA thing that was just a total
and complete and utter fabrication. Pisco
never admit this
>> um because it doesn't matter. And by the way, that's
because listen, I'm going to go on a rant that I stole from from
Terry a little bit, but uh >> go off. >> Um that's
because Pisco is principled. Pisco would defend uh Nick Fentes.
You'd defend Hassan. He would defend you. He's been on Twitter
defending Destiny, for Destiny getting demonetized, for Destiny
getting after by everybody over his speech. And he totally disagrees
with the speech, by the way. He completely disagrees with it.
>> Yeah. And he literally made the list on Twitter. But
most of the time you guys do not make lists of people's names.
But Pisco brave enough to make a list of people he would defend.
Destiny and Hassan on the list. >> Yeah. And like that's
just how he is. And then Desi only can see that like oh in this
one case where you were maintaining your principles,
right? You defended Hassan. You're supposed to be on my side.
You defended Hassan. >> Exactly. Because doesn't know what
a principle is. He only knows uh you are friend or foe. It's
us verse them.
>> Me? Well, Peter at his finest, >> I don't even
know. It's like It's like me versus them and then there are some
people who can kind of >> no, no, it's us. It's us because
all of our survival hinges on whether or not I get to do exactly
what I want to do. >> Yeah, he's Destiny is sitting here
as Ozel says here as well. Pisco should be cheering. He This
is Destiny's opinion. Pisco should be cheering just like I am
that Hassan might get banned because of Republicans, right? That's
That's like Desessie's opinion. Don't you understand that we're
on the same side? Just like you said, we're on the same side.
Don't you understand? We have to go after that guy. That guy's
going to destroy us.
>> uh, no, I think um I think the leftists haven't shown
any proclivity to to gain power, to do anything useful. I'd rather
focus on the Trump administration is Pisco's like response, right?
>> that seems to make a lot of sense. >> Well, you
could say that that makes sense, but
Job, how do I say his name? Job. I forget all his term. He brings
up a good point is how he feels about Myin. Do you remember when
things came out and he's like the only good response was Myin
and Myin's response was
that 304?
>> Or 403, whatever the those losers say.
>> They disagree on politics. They disagree everywhere
else. But this guy said the woman trying to sue me for what I
did to her. That's that's a principled person. >> Yep.
That's the only principle Dessi cares about is loyalty. It seems
like Benny says leftwing less funny Trump and I gotta agree.
It's like >> it's just a lot of the same tactics and it's
it's just pretty transparent and once you're on the outside it
just looks kind of weird to everybody else. >> But Benny
has he always has it always been this unfunny?
>> I feel like as soon as life got real as the sense of
humor went out the window. >> It it did. It did. Or did
I just have did I just have rose tints on where used to be funny
like 2 years ago? >> Maybe that's my fault. >> No,
no, no, no, no. He used to be funny because he had a lot of funny
people around him who would help out. Okay. And I think I think
when you're less spiteful, you are more funny. Like you can be
funny making fun of people when you're not like in a spiteful
like angry place. You can be funny in a way that you can't when
you're like super spiteful and just like going after. >> True.
True. >> So I think that's also a big thing there. I just
saw Max 15 minutes ago did his six month celebration and said
watch your raging tomato vod. We should watch all cultured thug
videos on the you and someday. I'm not sure about that Max but
thank you for showing your support. Appreciate it buddy. Appreciate
it. Appreciate you.
Uh let's continue on with this. Let's see whenever he makes up
some new story like the whole Pisco um TSA thing that was just
a total and complete and utter fabrication. Pisco will never
admit this. Um, I have no ability to communicate basically with
anybody in my arena because they're either too afraid of my reputation,
too afraid of getting doxed or harassed by people around me or
will get bullied by other weird like anti-fan communities like
Queen Magistical and Aaron or whatever.
So, when he's in he's in list mode here, I I I just want to keep
pointing out to you guys. You got to slow him down when he's
in list mode because he just says dumb things all the time. >> Yeah.
What was that? >> So, apparently he disconnected me, Queen
and Aaron in a way from like the doxing stuff. He's so scared
of getting doxied or doxed or getting harassed or getting bullied
by these other people. So, I don't know if he's had conversations
where he like puts the three of us into a different category
now. >> Also, is that what we're calling bullying by criticizing
people on their positions? They're getting bullied. That is so
that that is revealing so much. So much. Does he feel bullied
when people criticize his unprincipled like takes >> Apparently,
that's what we're going to refer to it as. Bullying. Bullying.
In case you guys didn't know, Destiny and DG are against bullying.
Someone let Max know. Let Mr. Girl know. That guy's never been
bullied by DGG once in his whole life. DG's against bullying,
guys. >> Never happened to anybody. >> It's It's
crazy. Also, I just And listen, if he wants to say me or Queen
and bully him, okay, that's fair. I I'll I'll accept that. Where
Straight Raid basically doesn't reference this guy. Straight
raid. The person straight rage bullies most is probably Pisco.
Like I haven't seen her like if she's I don't think she necessarily
bullies a lot of people. She makes fun of people. Obviously she
can be mean, right? That's her bit. But like I probably get directed
more at Pisco than other >> Is that a bit I just feel like
that is a good strong
trait in a person is the ability to lay it on thick. >> Okay.
Yeah.
I was going to say her bit is kind of just being I listen I'm
to my core sometimes. Okay. Her bid is just being a [__]
on stream. And it's funny. >> That's not being a You don't
know what a [__] is. And you're going to find out
one day. You You will find out one day. >> I said,
"Okay." Um
>> she So, she is funny, but I don't understand how how
does she get referenced in the same breath as me and Quimman?
Cuz I don't know if you've seen his opinions on Queman or me,
but it's like these I want these guys. I want these guys doxed.
So, how is he including straight? Like, I feel like he's just
figured out that other people don't like Straighter for the stuff
that went down with the DMs where he defended her, by the way,
completely. He defended Straight, said, "No, she didn't do anything
wrong. No, I think she's actually like a good person, right?"
>> And now he's flipped for no reason. I don't even know.
>> I can see a few reasons. I don't want to openly speculate.
>> Okay. Well, >> I can see a couple. >> Yeah.
Uh, but there are a couple people who don't like Aaron who uh,
we don't have to speculate,
not openly. >> Uh, Kathy asks, I don't even think Aaron
has her own community, does she? She does have her own community.
It's not like huge right now, but she is. >> No, she is
a small streamer growing. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Picking
on Aaron right now when literally her entire online existence
came up through DGG.
>> like streaming wise, she's not going to have she's not
going to have much of a bridge there with um President Sunday.
That was her OG community. You would say that she's starting
from scratch.
And I think having a show with Pisco I that was like really cool
of him to do. >> Yeah. Yeah. And I think um >> she's
got friends, she's got a network that's not a community. >> I'd
say she's got a network. Yeah, that's a better way to put it.
>> She's got a network of friends. That's not having a
community. That's not having your like a hardcore fan base.
>> I think they should grow. Like she should grow. She
should be doing good. >> And I think in a year she should
surpass
>> maybe. I I do think she's got a lot of room to grow.
I think the thing that is tough is cuz I see it a little bit
and I'd imagine it's tough for her too is if you have a large
community who dislikes you when you're a smaller creator that
can cause like algorithm issues.
You know what I mean? like where where people are like going
to follow you just to talk or just to like not like your stuff
that can cause some >> but she's not even engaging in those.
So
>> um no she's not she's not like engaging in criticisms
but people will just like who who are getting directed by like
Destiny right now trying to tie her to me or Queman. Right. I
think that's like another thing that uh I think that's another
thing he's like trying to do is try to tie her to me and Queman.
I don't think she necessarily hates that, but to Destiny's community,
that will kind of put her on the outside totally, right? >> Good.
Good. I being tied to his community in that way would probably
hurt her more. >> Uh, it could. Yeah. I do think uh I do
think she can grow a lot though cuz the thing that like I didn't
know about Straight Raid that now has become >> She's a
[__] nerd >> is that she's a nerd. She'll like
read. >> How did you not know that? >> I don't know.
She refused to like come on streams and talk like all the time
for a long time. >> But yeah, she is like a total politics
nerd. She and like not just like she reads for stream because
I know I read for stream and like I I like politics but she reads
like a lot off stream just for her own interest just like for
>> Okay, hold on cuz we're we're glazing a little bit too
much. >> Okay. She's also a leftist. Let's keep that in
mind. >> She also wants all Americans killed. >> No.
No, she doesn't. >> Wait, what? >> What? I thought
she wants them all dead. Anyone who owns private property dead
in a in a ditch. >> You think all Americans own private
>> Exactly. So, not all. >> Well, a good chunk.
>> I've heard this. Okay. People have told me this. Have
you guys heard about this? I feel like >> I like Aaron
cuz she is informed on her position and she'll have her position,
right? She doesn't like hide it. That's why she was like super
good on a panel with Veto. That was just like an interesting
back and forth.
>> Yeah. Yeah, >> she could take a troll or a meme
lord.
>> Yeah, she's a lot better thinking on her feet than she
is than her podcast
>> I was joking when I said that she'll be bigger than
Pisco in a year. That That's just a That's just a meme. >> Just
a meme. Okay. >> But I think she is like uh
I don't know. I hope I see her do good in this space. >> Yeah,
I think she will. Anyway, uh Destiny talking about how just
uh he like lists the same things over again. he merges categories
when he's in this like listing victim mode. It's just goofy.
I think it's weird to go after straight raid in any way for him.
I just think it's uh I I don't even know. I I like have suspicions
on why it happens, but it's uh >> this is this is benevolent.
Is that what it's called? >> Benevolent misogyny.
>> Benevolence. No, benevolence.
>> It's Sorry. Can I Can I explain? >> Can you man
explain it to me, dumb?
Stop. You defend Queen as much as you defend Aaron. We have to
We are supposed to protect women and children. You only defend
Aaron because she's a woman. Defend Quean, your child. >> Why?
Wait, where am I not defending >> Because you're like,
"Oh, it's fine for him to go after me and Queman." But Aaron,
why Aaron? >> Yeah, Queman. Quean's like the uh 13-year-old
at the mall who makes fun of your pants or something. Okay. >> That's
That guy That guy is a bully. >> No, he's not. He's hardly
a bully. He's so harmless.
>> Okay. Uh, all right. I feel gas lit now, so I'm going
to hit play. >> Other weird like anti-fan communities like
Queen Magistical and Aaron or whatever. Um, I I I don't want
to say I was targeted, but I like I've kind of gotten singled
out a little bit, but like on international or national social
media platforms, plus Fox News plus everything else. Um, I have
to I've kind of been singled out a little bit. I wonder how that
happened. This is like basically entirely disconnected again
from his previous statements, right? Like I've been singled out
on national international plat because of his comments about
how conservative scared >> but like what is he trying to
signal out the things I said
>> people are noticing them.
>> And if you guys remember when he was debating Soy Pill,
Soy Pill's like Soy Pill's like asking him why he says this and
Dusty's like, "Yeah, how do you think?" Soy Pill's like saying,
"You're on this panel saying crazy." And he's like, Dusty's like,
"How do you think I got on there?" And Soy Pill's like saying
crazy. And he's like, "Yeah, exactly." It's like the stuff he
strategically says to get people's attention, right? And then
he's like, "Oh, I've been singled out unfairly." No, you literally
put up a flare and we're like, "Can you guys single me out, please?
This is why you're supposed to feel disgusted making yourself
a victim of your own behavior, your own actions. You are supposed
to you're supposed to have this instant disgust reaction because
it's like, "Oh, all of these terrible things that are happening
to me are happening because of the things that I did."
>> What is anyone else supposed to do for >> It's
uh Yeah. I have no idea what how how like I anybody by the way
anybody who does try to help him on this who goes this is what
you shouldn't do he totally ignores them he totally talks about
them like they're losers right >> because he doesn't want
them to tell him what he should do differently he wants them
to go out there and normalize his behavior the same way that
Trump doesn't ever want to be told
oh this is unconstitutional you're going to break this rule you
should try this way no no just go out there and be a sickopant.
That's all I want. I need to look strong. Don't make Don't put
me in a position where I have to listen to your advice and look
>> Sorry, I just Yeah, just >> that's what he want.
>> That's what he wants. That's like exactly the behavior
he wants more than anything in the whole world is for people
to go out and do this tweet.
Like no matter what I do, you have to go out and basically like
be like, "Yeah, that's awesome." Like, no, it's not. You don't
have to do that. Yeah,
>> it's goofy. All right.
>> Um I I don't want to say I was targeted, but I like
I've kind of gotten singled out a little bit about like on international
or national social media platforms plus Fox News plus everything
else. Um I have to like semi be concerned about getting at an
event knowing that if I die basically every single person on
every single side of the political aisle is going to either blame
me or laugh at me for it. Um I've lost like a fairly big >> laugh
at me
>> going to laugh at him. I don't like the thing is is
I don't know. I think a lot of people don't want him like
I feel like a lot of people don't want him shot. Like unfortunately
he's done a lot of things where where to me like no that's you
getting away without actually seeing any ramifications for your
behavior. Like no I'd like you to be around because you should
face some kind of like ramifications for the behavior you've
engaged in. I don't I don't want you to I don't want him to go
out to like events with no security and take risks like that.
I would rather >> I don't want that either. I would love
be able to sign charges eventually. >> Like that that's
what I'm waiting for. So I don't know. I I hope he knows that
we wouldn't celebrate. Okay. We don't want that. We want him
safe and sound.
yeah, we want I just want ramifications. That's all. Revenue
stream from YouTube. Assuming the demonetization is permanent.
It's probably about a million dollars of money just gone per
year. Um, I'm still being bled on this stupid
>> And just real quick, because obviously there's the whole
like everyone wants their personal justice for what has been
happened to them, yada yada yada. I also wouldn't want him to
go out because I think I think before the end of his life, he
should have to get to diamond in League of Legends. Like that
should be his punishment. >> Okay. You understand that
he's like too old to do that now and you're just cursing him
to like eternal life, right? where he just ages and becomes less
and less capable of ever ending his own >> If he gave a
single about democracy,
he would do it. >> I He's incapable.
>> He's Yeah, he's just incapable. It's over. Um I'm looking
for Also, >> but he's talking about the money he lost.
And I think I know where you're going with that. >> Yeah.
Well, I I just asked um Riyle if anyone has the clip where he
talks about getting demonetized. There's like a clip where he
actually reads the um the email being demonetized. I do want
to see that as well. >> Side of the political aisle is
going to either blame me or laugh at me for it. >> Um now
I've lost like a fairly big revenue stream from YouTube assuming
the demonetization is permanent. It's probably about a million
dollars of money is just [__] gone per year. Um I'm
still being bled on this stupid court case. This is why I say
you have to get to diamond in League of Legends because it is
challenging and you are in ELOS with people who deserve to be
there alongside of you and you have to participate with a team.
You actually have to work alongside people. And I feel like for
as long as he's been out of league, he's become more and more
>> Sure. He needs to start being put in situations where
he is on par with everyone around him. And if he fails,
>> he's going to feel that. >> And yeah, and then
if he um >> and then if he has a teammate that carries
him, he will also feel that. I did not deserve this win. But
thank goodness there are people in the world who can carry him.
>> Empathy, he'll be rewarded for his empathy. If he like
doesn't tilt out, if he doesn't like lose his mind on people
and and like crash the out, he'll be rewarded for that. He'll
get yolo. Yeah. Okay. I'm seeing it. I'm seeing the vision a
little bit. We can teach this guy to be a human. >> League
of Legends therapy. >> One ranked match at a time. >> I
don't think it'll work, but it's a >> I don't know what
I'm cooking here. Just keep playing the league. >> Um,
so yeah,
I think it's it's just crazy to me. I also want to know. I have
no idea. He talked about how like, oh, if they can do the next
thing they're going to do, it's even crazier. I wonder what the
next thing they're trying to do for this case is because he he
hypothesized yesterday, I think, about Pixie being rich because
of how she was going to continue the case. And I actually don't
know what that meant. I I kind of hope it's subpoenaing Rose,
but I don't know. I actually don't know on this because she's
relying on a mentally ill girl who is Oh, hold on. Hold on. This
is uh him revenue stream from YouTube. Assuming the demonetization
is permanent. It's probably about a million dollars of money
is just gone per year. Um I'm still being bled on this stupid
court case. um where this stupid is like literally trying to
eat as much money as possible knowing that she's completely lost
on this because she's relying on a mentally ill girl who is like
outwardly and openly dodging my subpoenas. Um that Oh, I don't
think Pixie was ever planning to win this case on that. I think
she wants discovery, right? That's the thing that Destiny wants
to avoid. That's the thing that Pixie wants is she just wants
Discovery to go through and see if he sent it to anybody else.
Like, show me where that is in uh like show me the URL. Let me
search all of his Discord logs for it. Let me search his Google
Drive. see if there's like any um any of those URLs going around.
That's what she's looking for, right? >> Also, the audacity
of him to call. Are you going to press? >> I was going
to hit it. Yeah. Yeah.
>> The audacity of him to be like, "She's relying on this
mentally ill bitch."
Whose fault is it that a lot of the people you slept with have
some sort of mental illness addiction issue?
You're making fun of the people you chose to fly out, you trusted.
And >> nobody even pointed out she was a I believe she
was a Was she not a teenager at that time? >> I have no
idea. >> I think she was 18, 19, 20 somewhere in there.
She was pretty young at that time as far as I know. I think Wes
mocked him for that, right? >> That is disturbing. >> Yeah,
I Yeah, but he uh he makes fun of his own choices all and nobody
will ever criticize ever for this, by the way, because she's
a white woman. Um,
apparently nobody will criticize
Abby
for dodging subpoenas because she is a white woman.
I He's just doing He's doing like the Marov chain thing where
he just says the words that he thinks would sound good to people,
but it's not even connected to any rational thought process whatsoever.
He's just like kind of [__] talking,
right? Like that makes no sense. That it makes no sense. It's
not even remotely >> Dude, he has lost it. He's lost. He's
not funny. He's not witty. He doesn't know how to land a zinger.
>> Yeah. I I feel like it was there. I feel like it used
to be there. >> It used to be there cuz he wasn't actually
filled with so much hate for >> Yeah. I think that's what
it is. Is like he has so much anger at people now and and you
just can't he can't be funny when when he feels that way. It's
just total losing uh totally lost cause right >> And it's
just like thing after thing after thing after thing after thing
after thing.
Um, it's just a lot to have to every single day. Like I'm staying
awake till 3 or 4 a.m. to try to like work my way through. Like
they gave discovery to us. It's like 15,000 individual text message
files. Like they put it in every single message in a different
file. So while I'm working on this and building through this
and then trying to write up other stuff and then try to like
respond to and like deal with, you know, like scheduling for
events and whatever business emails and whatever other stuff
and just it's a lot of that's like constantly going on at all
points of my life. And then every single person that's in my
immediate orbit, I always have to be ready for them to flip almost.
>> I just wanna I just want to point out that he prefaced
this like two-minute rant with, "I don't want to be a victim,
but I don't want to be a victim, Andy, >> let me figure
out how I can twist this and be the victim. >> I don't
want to be a victim, but
here's like a here's a massive list of all the things that have
gone wrong in my life in the past couple weeks, guys." >> And
here is how it's everyone's fault, but my own. >> Everybody
else's fault almost immediately. So, I can't have any friends
in the industry whatsoever because all of them will flip on a
dime if the slightest amount of pressure no offense to anybody.
I understand it's hard, but if the slightest amount of pressure
is applied to anybody, they will instantaneously leave. Um, it's
just there's just like a lot. I think every one of the Lib and
Learn guys said like Destiny shouldn't be cancelled for this.
He shouldn't be banned, but I disagree with the rhetoric. They
gave him a defense. They were willing to defend his platforms,
all of them, right? And he won't even he won't even take that
little bit that they shouldn't probably even give up. They should
probably not even risk defending him at all. Like it's actually
bad optics. It looks bad for them. It could be used against them
later. Like realistically, if they were purely money motivated,
purely clout motivated, they would not even mention him. They
would just ignore it, right? But they don't want to do that.
They actually go and they they do try to give him like the defense
on the platform thing and he can't even accept that. He's just
like, "Nobody's nobody's mad enough to offend me on any of this."
And unfortunately,
he he literally means like nobody's man enough to lie for me
on this because he wants people to say the same he was where
he's like I just wanted everybody to have a healthy fear of political
violence. >> He wants everyone to do what Connor is doing
and explaining why actually the fact that I'm a grifter betraying
my principles is is to uphold my >> No, you don't understand.
I need the money and the clout, the influence, the power, I need
all of that so my family can be good. You're literally trying
by holding me to my principles. You're trying to orphan my kids.
I hope you understand that, guys. >> Yeah. Do you guys
understand? Like most people growing up in the country now are
not going to be able to afford a home. But because I work with
Steven, I'm going to be able to afford a home. Okay. >> That's
baffling stuff. Are you guys sharing a mic? No, we have two different
mics and we can uh Well, I'll I'll have them separated, I think,
for tomorrow. I have to figure out some stuff in >> mind
business. Why are you asking about our mics? I have to figure
out some stuff in >> we're sitting at like desks on opposite
ends of a room and that's why we have two different mics but
they're going through the same mix. >> Stop boxing where
we are.
everything constantly.
And yeah, it's just a lot. Like I'm having to like like field
like emails for like emergency motions that the other side is
bringing up to do like the weirdest in the world like on the
same morning that I'm also trying to like talk to uh whatever
mainstream media wants to do interview while I'm also like trying
to set up like a thing outside to make sure I'm not going to
get shot and it's just like while Hassan is also like reing on
my 14-year-old son like
uh pause. Okay. Also, what the is going on? Like literally, I'm
sorry. You still probably make more than a million dollars a
year. Hire a personal assistant. It sounds like you've got too
many things going on. Hire a personal assistant or just get
>> Isn't that what Nino is a personal >> Oh, I thought
so. Well, I don't know anymore. I I actually have no idea to
be fair. This is the thing is he he doesn't trust anybody to
do for him.
That's like the big deal. Uh there's a probably a reason he doesn't
trust anybody to come through his logs. I'll be honest with you.
>> He's got he's got a lot of secrets. >> I think
he's got a lot of secrets.
A mill a year. Not anymore. Um what is he getting like 2K on
kick right now? >> No. Okay, stop it. Because we watched
him talk about how much money he was making in stocks earlier
this year when he was like just I think in between talking about
the lawsuit and how ridiculous it was that Pixie wanted any money
from him, he just started like bragging about how much he was
making from stocks. So, look, I've got this in here and oh, I
just made 200,000 from this stock going up or whatever like >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> Like, he's so bad at playing the victim because
he forgets that there's so many times over the year where he
needs people to see I have money, I'm rich, maybe I'm going to
start investing in this or maybe I'm going to start um collecting
something. What do you do when you have a lot of money? There
are so many moments of him talking about like that. >> Yeah.
And I just I don't know why he's not got like a personal assistant
who's helping with this other than the fact that he's got the
secrets. >> I was say why doesn't he have a PR person?
But isn't that his lawyer? >> Also, Erodite. But yeah,
>> I feel like he like Erodite was supposed to help with
a lot of this stuff. And just feel like he's I I just remember
the what do you do you not remember the the rants last year about
he's like working with Arerodite and he's ranting about how hard
it is to find people who are good employees?
>> No, but he didn't have that conversation with her. He
hired her. I think the podcast still hadn't started yet. And
he just talked about how hard it is to hire good employees. Yeah.
>> Crazy stuff.
>> The thing outside to make sure I'm not going to get
shot and it's just like while Hassan is also like reing on my
14-year-old son like on his stream as I'm doing that. It's just
like a lot of constantly. And I'm not trying to say that like
Yeah. Who's the guy who like I don't know if you realize this,
but if you if only there was like a way for a parent to prevent
their child from uh from having like a significant online presence.
If only that was possible. If only there was somebody who could
>> make a decision to protect their their child from like
online online >> clout chasing morons. If only there was
a way might involve being involved, which would be a lot of work,
>> but like I don't ever also he didn't care when uh what
was it? Food shops. He raided into food shops and food shops
reacting to that same interview.
>> Did Han actually do it? Hzan has made fun of him for
having a son who is a groper. Yes. Yes, that's happened. That
has happened. Uh I will say this is probably the most attention
Nathan's ever gotten from his dad is Nathan has now become something
he can victimize himself with. And hey, now now I can start bringing
it up all the time. Guys, people are going after my son all the
time. All the time. the way to victimize himself again. Oh god,
there's some comparisons to Hassan there that I'm engage in.
>> We we used to make fun of Hassan for using the Palestinian
killed kids. Okay. The Palestinian kids >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I see it. But the thing is, no, cuz that implies that
the baby is a shield,
>> right? I'm pretty sure his kid insults him back. >> That's
true. That is true. >> Constantly. And I'm not trying to
say that like Yeah. Well, I'm not trying to do like a wo is me
thing. I'm just saying like, oh, and then >> yes, you are,
>> dude. On both ends. I don't want to be a victim, but
here's all the ways I'm a here's all the ways in which I'm a
victim. And, you know, I'm not trying to do a wo is me thing.
You know, getting email at the same time saying my YouTube is
canceled. I'm like, okay, well, that's great. You know, there's
a lot of stuff at all points in time. Always.
>> Okay. Okay, so we had that clip yesterday.
I've got a clip here from today as well. Let me find it really
Where's this clip? Oh, right. Another clip where he is uh talking
about again. I think there's an essential part of me here. Hold
on. Let me pull it back. Let me loud. >> I think this is
an essential part of media strategy. Hassan is so good at it.
He does this every day. Okay. The
I can't do it. I hate talking about myself like this. Connor
came in yesterday. I victimized myself a little bit. I hate it.
I hate being treated like a victim. It drives me
I find that what he really likes doing is saying that he doesn't
like being treated like a victim. Okay. It's like some reverse
psychology.
It's like some super reverse psychology. I hate being treated
like a victim. I hate being I hate it when I and and then he
goes and victimizes himself and it gets all of DG to soo him.
Right. >> And I think it's disgusting. I think if you truly
hated being treated like a victim, you wouldn't say this. >> Yeah.
You could never say this.
>> this is indicative of low testosterone, high estrogen,
and possibly
a vitamin D3 deficiency
>> possibly. But I guess since somebody heard me talking
last night, somebody did me the favor of not only spotting me
this morning, but also my parents, too. So, thank you for that.
Um, I know 100% for sure now. My mom and dad are very safe. There
are absolutely no bombs in their house. I've never been more
sure than right now that my parents house is bomb free and the
sergeant and the um for the Miami You are not supposed to talk
about this stuff by the way, just so you guys know. You're not
supposed to come on the internet to >> Yeah, he knows.
But here it is. Apparently, this is the the full-on I all I can
tell you is I've never seen somebody who starts engaging with
like KF and like a logging or or even more nefarious communities.
I can never tell you somebody who engages in that stuff and then
comes back and does like normal content creation like effectively
like it just it always goes it's always this like spiral down
into like destruction. I'd also just like to remind you
uh since we're saying uh hey you you know you shouldn't do this.
This is the that he criticized Pixie for. I can't believe you
sued me. I can't believe you wrote that Substack. Do you know
people would have forgotten if you just didn't say anything about
it? Oh, were you hurt by what happened with those leaks? If you
just never sued, people would have
>> Listen, I know this bothers you, but if you just let
three days go by, people will forget about it and move on. Yeah.
>> Don't Don't like talk about it. Don't This is like the
classic advice over everything, right? >> Yeah. If you
pay attention to it, if you acknowledge it, they're just going
to do it more. Then they understand what hurts >> Police.
She usually calls me when I got swatted to tell me like, "Hey,
so just checking, are you your girlfriend? Are you jumping off
your balcony?" I'm like, "Nope, not doing any of those today."
But they still have to send officers by to do like a welfare
check because they can't ignore calls like that. So that's why
my intro screen was like 15 minutes. Also, I'm Can you pretend
I said all this with tears? cuz it's I'm crying and it bothers
me a lot. Okay.
All right. There. Okay. That's my daily
Uhhuh. Guys, it doesn't bother me. I have to mention it, but
it doesn't bother me. It doesn't bother me. Doesn't bother me.
But I have to do this because Hassan does it. That's the that
What is that weird cut in the the weird like reference in the
middle or sorry, at the >> At the beginning. I don't know.
And then at the end where it's like, "No, no, no, but like I'm
super masculine. Like, trust me, I'm crying. Trust me." Wink
Just so you know that I pretended to be a victim. I'm just playing
it up so I can have like some sympathy publicly, but like not
even a tear in my eyes, guys. Swear. Swear. >> Yeah. Tequila
Sunset points out that uh this wasn't like he didn't get swatted
because obviously when the cops know, they send like people um
if they send like a SWAT team or something, which I believe I
have no reason to think he lied about. It did happen to him when
his kid was there. Like I I have no reason to think he lied about
that. But once that happens once and they realize it's fake,
they write it down so they don't waste the resources of doing
that [__] again. Right. >> Well, he says he
says they gave him a call. Um, >> well, he said a wellness
check showed up to his house. >> Oh, okay. >> At
the end there. Yeah. >> And then I don't know what he's
talking about with his parents and he's sure there's no bomb
there. That might have been a swatting >> different like
bomb threat or something. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. I
have no idea. >> But I'm just saying that like uh when
he says, "Oh, I got swatted this morning." It's like that's not
swatting. Uh, it could be an attempted swatting, but it's like
not working.
Obviously, they know that you're you're like not have you don't
have somebody at gunpoint right now. It's just it's just goofy
when when you have to redo these things like over and over again.
You shouldn't even engage with it, but then you do and then you
have to like use this extra language
and, you know, it's it just gets goofy. I just thought it was
weird that he talked about how >> central part of media
strategy. Hassan is so good at it. He does this every day. Okay.
Um, >> Hassan's so good at victimizing himself. He does
this every day. Okay. All right. Anyway, I think that's about
it for Listen, I had those two clips and I just thought they
were quite funny back to back. Um,
there's one other clip I wanted to look at, which was him reading
the demonetization email, but because I'd heard and I'm not 100%
sure on this, but I'm I'm like 80% sure it's 90 days, right,
until his next appeal. He is demonetized for 90 days and then
in 90 days he can appeal again. Can anyone confirm that for me
who's been following the situation closely?
Yeah, some people are saying yes. Okay.